[Music]
it's okay I'm here I'm here it's been a
while since you've had one of those
nightmares tell me what was it
about it's only
fragments nothing's
[Music]
clear you've been fighting the hinin for
decades look
my family's been fighting them for
centuries your blood comes from Dukes
and great
houses here we're
equal what we do we do for the benefit
of
[Music]
all I'd very much like to be equal to
you maybe I'll show you the
way
deal with this Prophet send assassins
fade rather he's
[Applause]
psychotic I see possible Futures all at
once and in so many futures or enemies
Prevail but I do see a way there is a
narrow way
through
[Music]
my allegiance is to you you believe
me this is a form of power that our
world has not yet seen the ultimate of
[Music]
power I want you to know I will love you
as long as I breathe you will never lose
me as long as you stay who you are
consider what you're about to do call a
tra this
silence this prophecy is how they
enslave
us you are not prepared for what is to
come
[Music]